[Music]
Texas is digging in after the Supreme
Court ruled that the federal government
can remove the barbed wire in Eagle Pass
Texas put in place by the Abbott
Administration to try to stem the flow
of illegal Crossings into America
joining me right now live from Texas is
the lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
Governor thanks very much for being here
this morning sure Maria assess the
situation for us in terms of that barbed
wire and what you're seeing uh with the
illegals coming across so I was down
there all day yesterday uh first to uh
let our Troopers our Troopers our DPS
Troopers and our soldiers know that we
have their back because they have Texas
back and America's back we have fine
young men and women Down On the Border
protecting our border uh in Shelby Park
let me give you an example we put up the
wire we put up containers and guess what
a few months ago 3,000 were crossing to
day Maria today zero zero yesterday when
I when I left around 4:00 in the
afternoon so we know what we're doing in
Texas works for the Biden Administration
and Joe Biden and mayorcas want to come
in and cut the wire when we're having
success makes no sense to anyone even
the rank and file Border Patrol on the
border that we work very well with Maria
it's just the politicos that he sends in
that try to stir the pot look they stood
down they said they're not going to cut
the wire and it's good news for them
because they would have needed a lot of
wire cutters because we have a whole lot
of wire and if they had snipped it and
cut it we we would have replaced it
right away we're going to put wire down
the entire border well that that is
going to be incredible pictures uh there
are cameras all over the place but it
will be really incredible pictures to
see the Biden Administration cut down
the wire that that you will put in if in
fact it goes that way but you know John
Ratcliff who warned us about this three
months into the Biden Administration
says that look we didn't have a problem
months ago I can tell you that that this
was an issue that the Biden
Administration uh selfin inflicted on
this country
why because he is wrongheaded on a long
list of issues okay we can make a long
list of issues but this border issue is
number one because fentol is crossing
that border and killing more Americans
than than any other issue between 18 and
45 because we have women being raped we
have children being put into sex slavery
we have murders we have molesters we
have gang members we have drug dealers
we have carjackers we have kidnappers
all Crossing with these millions of
people and and he is wrong on this issue
he doesn't care because here's the
agenda Maria America has to understand
their agenda is they don't care if
people die if they make their goal and
what is their goal to put millions of
people into this country one day turn
them into citizens and one day turn them
in the voters and take over the country
that's their goal and we all know it so
how much yeah how many people would you
say have crossed into America illegally
on Joe Biden's watch I mean there are
numberers 8 10 million I want to get
your assessment the lieutenant governor
of the state how many people I've been
studying this for 15 years I track I
track it by the year pretty much and my
and my data matches up much with mit's
data in 2016 we were averaging about
435,000 apprehensions most years think
about that per year and in December we
had 300,000 alone so under Joe Biden we
know the apprehensions the people who
come across the bridge and turn
themselves in want to even though 90%
don't qualify for it uh we will be
somewhere around 8 million with the Goda
ways at the end of Joe Biden's turn
maybe as many as 10 million wow now
Maria we don't catch everyone so if you
get one out of two we have 1250 miles of
border with Mexico our border Texas of
Mexico is further than the distance
between Atlanta and Portland Maine so
there are people get in that we don't
see so if you get one out of every two
that's going to be 14 15 16 million
people that have gotten into this
country since Joe Biden has become
president that would make them just
alone if you put them in one area the
seventh largest state it would be the
state of illegal immigrants after
California Texas Florida New York
Pennsylvania Illinois the state of
illegal immigrants and look there are
many people coming here for a job and a
better life but that's not our concern
Our concern is protecting Americans and
protecting Texans from the criminals
that come and from the drugs that come
in and let me tell you this Maria this
is a stat that many people have never
heard we've arrested
13,1 63 Smugglers since we started
operation lonar several years ago 90% of
those Smugglers are US citizens the drug
cartels work with the gangs to
distribute their drugs they also work
with the gangs to give them specific GPS
coordinates where to pick up people
crossing the border illegally this year
we passed Senate Bill four I believe was
the exact number Senator Pete Flores
passed this bill that now in Texas when
we arrest you you're an American citizen
a minimum of 10 years in prison if
you're a Smuggler but imagine that
13,000 Smugglers almost all US citizens
90% in coordination with the cartels
that's why Maria when I say it's an
invasion it is an invasion it's a cartel
Army you know the founders never dreamed
we'd have a president like this one it
would just open the door to everyone and
and he said well Invasion if if an army
came well we're facing an army we're
facing an army but and they're well
armed they're well coordinated they're
making millions and millions of dollars
off of Joe Biden Don't Mess with Texas
we're serious about securing our border
and I'm glad the president stood down on
Friday and did not confront us that
would be the wrong thing to do we don't
want a confrontation and they shouldn't
want a confrontation we're just our job
let us do our job because I mean what is
this going to turn into a Civil War I
mean you've got the Texas rights versus
Federal rights both sides with
guns and we believe constitutionally we
are right we have a right to defend our
citizens we have a right to defend this
country and we're just doing the job
this whole idea of Shelby Park that they
would come there is just ludicrous look
these young men and women who serve our
National Guard and our DPS these are the
best of the best why would he want to
send anyone down to confront them I'm
glad they Ste down uh but they need to
do the job and the only reason he's
paying attention now is because the
election of November that's the only
reason he's paying attention real quick
on the Chinese Nationals we've seen up
1,00% uh you know military AED men what
are they doing here what's your
assessment we apprehended someone from
Lebanon the other day what's he doing
here why are they here from Syria why
are they here from Nigeria why are they
here from most of the countries in the
world how did they get here who's paying
for it um look the Chinese Nationals
when I first went to the Border in 2007
as a freshman Senator uh I saw signs in
in Chinese Mandarin at that time 2007 we
already knew they were coming back then
so we are being invaded make no mistake
one message America we're being invaded
Joe Biden mayorcas Kam kamla Harris all
are lying about it as I call them along
with Jean Pierre they're The Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse and the last
Horsemen in scripture says and death
came with them and every death whether
they drowned in the river whether
they're killed in America whether it's
by MS13 they're all on the hands of Joe
Biden thank you so much Lieutenant
Governor Dan Patrick we so appreciate
your time this morning we'll keep
watching hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-host Harris vulner
and Kaye mechineni on outnumbered every
weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or sets
your DVR also don't forget to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights